death threats that I'm gonna be shot
threats of my mother was gonna be
kidnapped and then also very very dark
statements about how Cecil the lion was
luckily lucky in comparison to my
animals my name is Thomas Chipperfield
and I'm a lion trainer the Lions I have
two beautiful male African lions Sava
and a cigar boy then my male tiger Altai
boy Altai just woke up haven't you go
good boy outside of my big cats my
collection involves at least eight
parrots all right guys the hello fling
no just wants to chew on my fingers
three boxes Ranger this is Lawrence
likely orphaned not a viable candidate
for release we've taken him in and he is
part of the family we have a skunk
this is Maddy well he likes to fight we
have a raccoon we just start to eat
dinner and Crockett decides to join us
from his cupboard cave
unfortunately Crockett is dieting so he
won't be joining us in our chicken
Kiev's an Asian Palm Civet this is Louie
at night the full moon syndrome comes
out
is unstoppable the possums and we have a
couple of snakes so this is grumpy this
is something's gone snake
grumpy certainly lives up to the name
but for the most part a very agreeable
snake this is royal Python clear my
family's background in the surface was
very very very big celebrated back in
the day is there a collection of over
300 animals that used to travel with
them and they were also the pioneers of
the drive through safari parks that
they're famous around the world I feel
that my upbringing in the circus has
given me a true appreciation for animals
and just a fundamental respect for them
as individual beings and their potential
my day normally starts in in the morning
first thing I'm going to do is to open
up my animals my big cats to let them
out Sabo Salva doesn't do morning skies
okay so we've got a phone call little
bit earlier from abattoir they've got
some pigs heads for us too
come and get that'll be good feed for
animals depending on however they are
between one to six per day per animal is
a typical feed when they get to meet
you've got the fat skin if you've got
the eyes were brain and soft block so
essential nutrients training for the big
cats is functionally what I would do in
the circus ring or on the film set just
something to keep them motivated and
interested oh boy all the basic stuff
that you do in dogs and this is stuff
that can be done with non domesticated
animals as well the parrots it's what's
called a recall where they will fly from
their station or their perch to you come
in a flame for the smaller animals that
would involve putting them on two leads
and collars and taking for walks
good Ranger people generally speaking
are surprised to see how quick and
enthusiastic wild animals are to learn
[Music]
working with big cats is what I would
call a calculated calculated risk
because they do have the potential to to
hurt you and to kill you but as long as
you treat them appropriately is what
makes all the difference this is what
happens when you forget to take your
shovel out of the lion enclosure before
you let the Lions out some of the yeah
the more what looked to be risky and
daring things I do would be with the
Lions like kissing and hugging the Lions
big jump over the top of me and then
also just some of the the faster route
choreographed routines where they do the
running and the jumping and I'm still
here so I think that speaks for itself
of course there - what I made of the
series Tiger King was it didn't do
exotic animal keepers like myself any
favors unfortunately
[Music]
but one thing it did do to our benefit
was it served as a great leveler in
terms of exposing the prophecy of the
animal rights side in the film it has
generated a lot of conversation about
what I do and then about about zoos as
well generally speaking and it's not
been fair criticism the more in in
inverted commas controversial side of my
work is people say animals shouldn't be
used in entertainment or exploitive
profit a lot of the public think that
zoos they return animals to the wild
they are protecting animals for the
future and their funding conservation
and while they all do do some of that
most of the animals in captivity are not
endangered so to me I still think zoos
our commercial primarily commercial
thing and I do think we should be phased
out my defense is that people like
seeing animals and the best way to
inspire people to care about animals is
to to behold them with their own eyes
and to experience their full potential
it's going down your sleeve
we're not positioned what I do has
gotten really extreme I've seen things
like people intruding on our our farm
late at night and then also threatening
messages sent to our social media and to
aspire the post things like threats to
to myself like death threats that I'm
gonna be shot threats my mother was
gonna be kidnapped and then also very
very dark statements about how Cecil the
lion was luckily in comparison to my
animals okay so this is the view from
out the back garden trying to avoid all
the major landmarks and nearby because
I'm quite used to having people of an
extremely entire letting up to me in in
January of this year 2020 the British
government introduced a ban on the use
of wild animals and traveling circuses
so we've had to drastically reach a
point we do with our animals in order to
keep them and also sustain ourselves
that's where the where the shift has
taken place from me moving primarily in
surface circles to working in the media
so I still get to work with my animals
and all the same ways I would in the
circus but without being able to share
them with the public on mass which to me
is I feel like I'm not giving as much as
I can as an artist our future
potentially involves us acquiring a plot
of land and opening our own private Zoo
I do intend to carry on with the work my
family have always done this is what
I've always wanted to do I feel
connected to animals far more than I
feel connected to people and I just
can't picture my life without them
[Music]